welcome to another episode of not too
deep I'm your host grace Helbig today's
a goddamn thrilling day we have a legend
among us today I'm talking drag queen
royalty absolutely fantastic comedian
internet sensation cheap wig putting
together champion except the list goes
on and on Trixie Mattel is here with us
today and she couldn't be more of a
delight I feel like we only scratched
the surface of the shenanigans that her
life has been since since drag race
since before drag race what she's got
coming up she's got so many things
somebody plates spinning and this was
just I'm still reeling I'm still reeling
enjoy this episode of not too deep with
Trixie Mattel how do you it's like
change up your makeup look if you do it
all cuz you have such a signature style
I don't change it too much because a
that's what my skill set is and B that's
kind of like what people come to see
right so if you did something
dramatically different do you feel like
you're letting people down I mean I
think this still looks like Trixie yeah
anything softer I would feel weird and
also I would start to feel uncomfortable
when used to this much camouflage yeah
you know you don't want to take
something off yeah I like to really feel
like a toilet you don't have synced yeah
yeah it's like a weighted blanket on
your face yeah I almost slept in it last
night yes of course I have it's awful it
always seems like a good idea because
like sometimes I'll have a late night
and then I have to work in the morning
yeah for some taping thing and sometimes
I'm like just sleeping it yeah I take
the lashes at one time oh my god so like
I'll wear one wig and I'll attach other
wakes to it for like updos and stuff
I'll take the updo piece off take the
lashes off reap outer everything and try
to like sleep like a vampire and then
wake up but then but then something
there's the responsible way of sleeping
in makeup and then there's the I came
home drunk yeah [ __ ] them tomorrow they
get what they get vision which is a
little more like I wake up it's like the
second summation yes pillow looks like
you know like me justice Preston and
that's almost worse because at a certain
point if you have to repair every future
in the face just start over yeah start
from scratch what about I mean because
you're innovative in the makeup world
now you have your own line and all of
that have you thought about innovative
ways I think a lot about why they don't
make pillowcases out of like you know
makeup wipes that you could just fall
asleep directly on like a Neutrogena
makeup wipe and just like toss and turn
all night and then it does the work for
you no that's a scam see I mean works
for one night disposable pillowcases I
think this is great I think that's a
great idea yeah I'm always open to new
ways to get makeup off you I mean a lot
of direct means get very creative I use
like a series of I use like an al baleen
product which is like a very heavy
theatrical like like almost like
Vaseline okay heavy goop ray yeah and I
do heavy goop to loosen everything and
then while it's all suspended in the
goop then I take a very gentle makeup
wipe and clean that and just wipe it off
and then wants to make us off I do a hot
hot towel to get out cuz you know I'm
glue in my brows and stuff
I'm usually I also shower what I've
learned to not take the makeup off in
the shower because it really makes it
hard for makes it hard job for the
cleaners is curious scene it's shocking
I know drag queens you Dawn dish soap
dish soap on their face on their face
Wow I know people who'd baby shampoo I
know people who do baby oil yeah um it's
there's no one product that everyone use
there's no miracle product everyone's
got their own routine yeah cuz when you
wear this much you sort of have to do a
double cleanse yeah did the makeup off I
mean you actually have to take care of
your face yeah I'm very blessed I mean
I'm in drag almost every day and I know
your skin looks amazing but I can't
really tell because there's a lot of
makeup on it especially since because I
started the cosmetics company this year
I'm also always trying new products cuz
I feel like I need to know what's hot
what's cool I was gonna ask because that
industry obviously is so competitive
right a lot of drag queens have gotten
into it a lot of you know content
creators have are in that world and it's
a very drama-filled world
but are you do keep up with like the
drama in the makeup yes I'm ready to be
canceled canceled yet no I'm always yes
I've been canceled for comedy makeup yet
there's still time there's still time
I think I solely got into this industry
because it seemed like it seemed like
there was this whole like you ever watch
a TV show and be like I wish I was in it
yes that was makeup drama for me and I
was like I wish I was in it I want to be
in there I want to get exposed because
it's so pretend and make-believe yeah
and I feel like as a drag queen coming
into the makeup industry it's also my
responsibility to sort of parity it in a
way sure I mean that's also your brand
to do stuff like that yes like yesterday
we wait today on my cosmetics account
it's like me and drag me like hey guys
it's me Trixie D today we have a special
promotion going on every single piece of
cosmetics is available for its regular
price I know brands every day it's like
40% off for five minutes like what is
happening yeah it's intense how much
like research did you do before you
launch your line going completely blind
and just being like I think this is
great as I haven't looked at any
competitors there any of the market or
any of the trends but this is what I
want well I have like a good decade of
experience in selling Trixie rights like
I do know what this looks like to people
and what it works how it doesn't work
yeah and before I did drag race and
stuff my day hustle was I was a makeup
artist at an Ulta a Sephora and then I
was as Mac for four and a half years Wow
so I full-time watch people shop for
makeup for a living which is extremely
educational I wonder about that do it
must be fascinating to watch people look
for makeup especially I don't know what
I'm looking for when I go into like a
Sephora or Ulta I can feel the burning
eyes of the people that work there
looking at me and knowing like she has
no [ __ ] clue what she's doing and
like slowly like encroaching on me and
me going because I don't like talking
and interacting with like people that
work in stores I'm just like I got it I
got I got it but clearly I'm likes
watching the absolute wrong color on me
and I can just feel like judgment from
afar
ooh is that the kind of people watching
that you've picked up on in working
there for so long
no it was a lot more like maybe it's cuz
I was male and maybe it's because I was
young but people would sort of like I
noticed that people women would feel
very disarmed by their makeup bags they
feel like society is expecting them to
wear makeup and they're expecting them
to know how to wear it right and so
there's no culture of asking or learning
or saying be educated to learn how to do
that yeah and so like I found that
normal boring people and fabulous drag
queens we all want the same thing we
want something that's priced well it
works well and it's easy if not fun to
use you can add a fun factor that's how
you put a love mark on something and I'd
noticed from drag the reason people like
drag is because adults just want to feel
like children for one second they just
want to feel like a kid that's true and
so for me it was like my makeup bag for
Trixie was all these pro products sleek
black packaging with great formulas and
then it was like my glitter stacker from
Claire's so that you put in your
caboodle yeah like my plain makeup yeah
so with my cosmetics I was like well can
we do this sort of like Tamagotchi Polly
Pocket My Little Pony packaging but can
we put pro formula in it
oh and so I love my products because you
get that little you get that little girl
moment yeah but you get an eight-hour
wear and a great finish and
yeah it's fun but also professional yeah
you know here's a tip for going to the
support as the girls on the YouTube do
this
if you go with no makeup on they do your
whole face or they think you're garbage
and they're like we're not helping her
go home okay got it I'm gonna go in my
comfy next time and just see what
happens
headphones yeah yeah that's sort of the
pair of verbal in the country till we
call that pair of verbal communication
Oh what does that mean communicating
without talking of like nonverbal please
don't come up to catch me it's like if
you're standing in a makeup collar with
your arms closed
that's not welcoming yeah I'm says I
guess the person that would be standing
in at Macy's like this yeah just like
the titanic's to like take me now cuz I
remember when I worked at Mac there was
a brand new I forget what she was she
was like some kind of regional
boss lady mm-hm and she weed none of us
knew she looked like and so she was
going to all the counters and fake
shopping like secret shopping learn and
one day she was she secret shopped with
us and then afterwards she was like it
was very like give me the keys and
taking over like [ __ ] she took off the
way yes yeah she was in a bat suit and
then she was just like a lot of you guys
were standing there with your arms
closed and that's parallel communication
that you don't want to help anybody it's
crazy how retail is everybody has a
retail story yeah but little did I know
I would go on to have the privilege of
having my own makeup company oh my god I
got the training of my life from all
those jobs
did you watch did the people shoplift oh
my first job was at t.j.maxx
and I worried like I was 16 and I worked
in the fitting rooms and I would just
kind of I was so shy so introverted and
I would watch adult women like blatantly
go in the fitting room with six items
come out with - and like have tags
underneath their clothes like obviously
shoplifting educators anything right I
was just like good for you like you I'm
not gonna say anything but like a little
cleaner anybody being paid at that level
enough money to like yes are you gonna
let her max wasn't giving me a bonus if
I reported anyone you know like Steven
Seagal start unscrewing the broom handle
like get ready to take this [ __ ] out
but did you watch did people like openly
shoplift in makeup stores oh yeah I mean
I found that like when I works at an
altar obviously we had fragrance and so
that's a higher price point so like and
at the altar I worked out you couldn't
say anything so like let's say you stole
this baby right I could walk up to you
holding another baby and be like did you
need help bringing something up ah you
can sort of suggest it you can't even
tell someone that like I saw you steal
the subliminal messaging of letting
someone kind of know if they read
between the lines yes I saw what you
were doing
yeah and you can't like chase them to
the parking lot you can't chase them out
of the story can say anything what start
at the store you can call the police
department but I guess then they're gone
right and what's the point and then when
I worked at Mac because that was kind of
my real big bread and butter of like
learning makeup and I was people would
still testers a lot which I was found
shocking
tester
still the tester me I mean that's me
seems like a bacteria covered like thing
everyone's touching yeah I mean or it's
just easier to steal who knows easier to
steal because at least at my store yeah
we kept the product out of people's
hands yeah we worked in kind of a
difficult area and so they would
probably met a lot of we have one of
those malls that like we would have lock
downs lock downs in the fights or like
you know when they had like one day
there was a flash mob at my mall and we
all got evacuated wait like a dance
flash mob no it was like a bunch of high
school kids agreed to show up at a
certain time in place and just start
breaking [ __ ] oh that's different than
what the like I remember I was doing
this girl's makeup and it was like we
got to go like drag your hands took her
outside so we're stayed in the parking
lot Wow because kids I've learned
through like social media that flash
mobs are like we show them we have a
choreographed dance that no one around
us knows that we're doing yeah well I
wish oh my god when you're a jet all the
way I know so that's why I do ecommerce
now try to steal for me warn you come
break into my house get out yeah you are
insanely busy yeah as well or you put on
the airs that you're insane they're busy
but you're doing so much [ __ ] right now
I was watching your documentary moving
parts which is you so fun so cool
how did did you feel nervous to agree to
do something like that like cuz that
feels like very intimate based on
everything else that's like I think a
little bit more presentational you know
that's really a good observation because
I think a lot of people think that
because I'm Trixie I'm all out there
sure what could be less out there then
every time you talk about yourself you
dress as someone else like and I'm very
private so for the Trixie thing I put
all my life into the jokes and the songs
and the looks but it's through this
trumpet it's not like my own voice you
know so for that movie my it's produced
by my boyfriend of three years right
which is another layer of it being so
intimate yeah we didn't tell anybody
because again I'm private I don't even
like people to know his Instagram so
like but obviously people can find if
they want but having somebody you trust
on the other side of
camera it was like a real definitely a
lubricant for certain conversations
mm-hmm I knew that no matter what you
know like on drag race if you might go
on there and say something really awful
they got you gal yeah and like there
probably is it yeah you don't have the
control over how the Edit happens yeah
but in this it was like I knew that
somebody had a financial investment in
me and also had a personal stake in
their not trying to get the gal right so
that was nice and honestly it was like
because I had just done drag race and
Trixie in Katja was hurting him by
Santos put it on my second record I was
doing this world tour it just seemed
like if we don't make like a snow globe
of this I'm it's gonna seem like a waste
and I'm gonna forget it because this
could never happen again
well that's the thing too right cuz it's
a it's like a personal like visual
scrapbook for you to look back on all
these like insane moments that are
happening they're so hard I'm sure to
like appreciate in the moment yes
instantly moving it is I mean I watched
some of those scenes that don't seem
important like there's a scene of me
standing in this I think it's like Grand
Clapham and loved in this big Hall right
mm-hmm and I've stayed in there tuning
my autoharp and I just remember I
remember tuning my autoharp but I don't
remember being like wow I'm tuning my my
[ __ ] Appalachian folk instrument to go
play for like 1200 people because it
doesn't feel cool in the moment because
you're just working right right right
like when I won drag race there's a part
in the film where the cameras were there
watching me find out I won the biggest
drag competition in the world yeah I
that moment just was like it was it
happened it was over and at the same
time it seems like the last forever it
was like my whole life frozen and it was
like watching it back I've only seen the
movie maybe twice because it's a little
intimate to watch some the parts and so
watching that part I'm like that is
magical
I'm so happy we have this like terrarium
of it yeah every time I watch it it's
like it's happening again
that's so cool yeah I'm very proud of
the movie again there's a lot of parts
especially with Katya especially with
parts about my family and it's not my
favorite thing to talk about but the
film did a really good job of keeping it
very intimate and very like Wizard of Oz
style like the man behind the curtain
yeah yeah it does it does feel that way
films almost like somber
and I think most people see me in comedy
and of course in comedy you're doing
your truth but you're doing it in a way
that gives everyone permission to laugh
this film has a lot of like not
punchline moments no that's what so I
find those moments way more interesting
than like the you know scripted bits in
the pre rehearsed you know stuff on
stage stuff like that like I like to see
the man behind the curtain I like to see
though all the little moments that get
you to being on stage and being able to
live your life out loud like that yeah I
think it's very very cool thank you well
the byproduct of that is there's
definitely parts in the film where I'm
like wow whoever was a fan of mine who
thought I was a real celebrity that
moment is gone like like me and my
garage rifling through boxes of gowns
like me at the airport pulling my own
suitcases it's great because I think
that's I've maybe a little bit of an
unidentified part of like drag is all
the behind the scenes all the schlepping
all the stuff that you guys do like
you're a one-woman show like you handle
so much of your business and there's not
even a woman a 1 a 1 muppet show it's
great ok let's talk a little bit Trixie
and Katya sure I'm obsessed with the
youtube series of Icelanders you are I
love it you have my friend mamrie Hart
on a while ago yes
icon yeah a couple years ago I was like
going through a breakup and I was just
like doing the sit in bed for a month
situation and I found the show on
YouTube and then all of a sudden an
episode I play and mamrie just walks on
I was like what the [ __ ] she knew so fun
I loved the editing obviously it's taken
on like a full life of its own
what was it like for you guys to start
working on YouTube to see like all like
because you can see numbers you can see
growth you can see like interactions
with people that must have been coming
from drag-race like kind of different
well yes and also um it was like YouTube
has changed so much like what's great
for us is drag queens we've always been
content creators and we've always had to
finance their own things and find a way
to do it bootleg right for us we like
realize that YouTube was a place where
we could have a lot of control and
fanbase is so young I think something
like I think something like like for
example I know for my cosmetics company
90% of our purchases are made on mobile
not on desktop Wow
that shows you how many people watch
things on tablets and phones versus
computers and TVs yeah so for us having
this short form less than 10 minute
high impact you can watch it a few times
and still find new jokes comedy series
that could be accessed by like high
school-aged kids yeah and we call it
like the toilet show like you could
watch it on the toilet you catch the
episode for the week mm-hmm it was a
huge advantage for Esme when I think of
what that show did for me and Katya's
careers it really changed the game
because we did drag race and that really
made people a fan of us and not just
drag race yeah did you guys become
friends through drag race and then kind
of decide to start this together I mean
we became we were friends on drag race
but not really like we were both so
grief-stricken trying to win this you
know Hunger Games situation bad we're
not like bonding but then after the fact
we we bonded a little bit and then when
we started this series we we discovered
we had this chemistry we didn't really
know really know we didn't really know
and then it was like when you watch the
show from episode 1 to I think like
we're on 120 now nuts you can really see
a friendship develop you can see in the
first 30 40 episodes we're asking very
basic questions about one another yeah
like you're getting to know each other
yeah you're watching two people like
court each other a little bit yeah and
we just go so well because it's like I I
think it's because I look crazy but my
POV in comedies a little more dry and
punchline II and like but it's yeah and
she looks normal
there's some red flags with her looks
like she looks normal until you look
again and realized there's a good bird
nest on the hair when you look a little
closer I know I was watching the holiday
one it's just like oh and there's an
actual manger on her head and by the way
we shoot on green-screen the Joseph was
paint was wearing a green robe and she
had two nail polish painted blue so if
you wonder where production quality is
they'll polishing a little baby Jesus
yeah but we've gotten really close and
we're really proud of the work and
honestly you know we both get to tour
the world and just so many cool things
that show how much do you guys prep for
the show before you shoot episodes or is
it really off the cuff is it really like
here's your let's talk about you know
cups and then you guys just go we don't
plan a thing while we're getting ready
that day usually the producer comes in
the provider with Pete who produces it
also films it and does audio well we are
its to drag queens in one person that's
the show that's me it's just like when
we were at the street we were nominated
for the stream year it's just crazy
yeah it's crazy YouTube people are
makeup people YouTube people are on
another level equal parts celebrity
equal parts shut-ins and everyone's
delusional and like some of these celebs
these YouTube slobs they're huge you
seem in real life in lil you're like
yeah like I just saw Jojo see wha who's
a young ponytail girl yeah um she's like
30 yeah she's got a she memory and I
always joke that she talks like she's
eating six boxes of cigarettes yeah I
mean she's a business mogul my niece was
her for Halloween and my brother showed
me like a photo and I was like yeah I
mean she looks cute she's a cute look
but I thought she was a kid
she got up this is like a developed
teenage girl with like makes me think
like a teenager
it makes me think like Disney's like
raise the camera and higher voice we got
to squeeze this you know like they're
trying to make it seem like like in five
years we're gonna be like she's still a
kid yeah maybe he's got a conspiracy
theory that she's like a 60 year old
Russian woman it's true that we lost the
we lost the Streamy again who'd you lose
to do you know lost to youtube series
escape the night oh yes yeah huge series
and we lost and of course we're bitter
and we're listening to this speech for
the winner and they go this is you know
for all 250 people who are on set every
day for this show and I'm like okay we
have me a green screen a crackhead
so like that we didn't win
we do so much with so little on that
show it's amazing but it's like that's
kind of how YouTube started you know
like that's the essence of it it's like
kids on their own adults on their own
trying to make stuff you know as best
they can with the resources that they
have yeah I mean and at this point
luckily our following is what the views
are so we haven't stopped because the
views keep going it's so we're not gonna
stop making them until they like drop
off and at this point if you've not seen
our show if you're like from fifteen to
thirty and you haven't at least heard
about the show on YouTube you've
actively tried not to hear about it yeah
yeah yeah because our thumbnails aren't
we become recommended videos for the
weirdest things because we have so many
topics yeah you cover a whole spectrum
if you watch a drag queen video or
makeup video we will pop up yeah
and then because we talked about breakup
and now that we're out of topics now
we're like let's talk about industrial
farming yeah we're so scraping the
bottom of the barrel the other day we
were like god we've talked about the
doctor but we've never talked about the
waiting room do you like crowdsource do
you ask people what they want you to
talk about no we honestly sometimes just
it goes from our moods or what's hot to
us I'm talking about like one day we
were in a terrible mood and I just said
we're gonna talk about crying and yeah
and that's a universal topic that a lot
of people can relate to yeah and like we
always do certain themed ones like
Christmas sure new year and some of the
topics you know some of this stuff was
40 plus years ago so some of the topics
I'm like I think we need to do food
again yeah bring 30 now talk about that
when I was 25 metabolism is different
now yeah it's been a great gig because
it's really sold us accidentally as a
package and so you know now we have our
show Queens who like to watch on Netflix
right so it's and we get to show up to
things together and host and because you
know doing improv with someone so long
you have so much trust that you can get
throw in anything and you're like we're
fine
also it's just fun because it seems like
you guys are genuinely trying to make
each other laugh more than trying to
make the audience laugh and there's
something about that that's just very
sweet to watch it's very cool we get
that a lot and that must be a really
true thing because a lot of people say
like it seems like you'd be doing it
even if we weren't
well it's also because you guys so often
and I think this is such a like small
minor detail but I like it so much that
you guys talk to like you look at each
other
you're not just presenting out to the
camera the whole time like you look
inward and actually have a conversation
amongst yourselves yeah and there's
something about that that's like I want
to be in on that conversation that
they're having yeah in front of me but
not with me right now
yes people sort of feel like people for
sorta feel like they're having a cup
there in the conversation yeah they're
overhearing you to talk in a corner yes
she is also I mean so many episodes
episodes in she's endlessly surprising
like her life like a final destination
that she's even still alive you just
wrote a book together Trixie yeah tricks
in Koch's guide to modern womanhood on
pre-order now an Amazon cool it's an
etiquette and Home Economics textbook
for young girls Wow we wrote it I love
it and uh you know even reading her
sections like I thought I knew her and
I'm like you are crazy there's a section
with haikus about getting your period
Wow she's a 40 she's a 40 year old man
Wow I mean but that just goes to show
the artistry that you guys aren't afraid
to dabble it really the authorities on
women's bodies probably you know way
more than most of the women in my life
so I will read that text book front to
back we definitely know about like hair
and makeup and we talk about breakups
and relationships and all that we do
know about I would say women's bodies
maybe speculations on your okay we're
gonna take a quick break when get back I
have a billion more questions for you
all so the Internet has a lot of
questions for video so we're gonna get
into that we'll be right back with more
not too deep
[Music]
do you guys have a safe word or
something established between the two of
you that like allows you to take space
without feeling offended by the other
one no you know I were the best of
friends
we're both solitary lone wolves oh okay
we call or text or probably every day
right cuz you've posted things that she
sent you like text messages and stuff
and like voice memos yes has there been
anything in particular that's like your
favorite thing or stuff that you're like
you've crossed the line you can't send
me this I I like it usually does some
when I text her it's because I'm in drag
and feeling it all said a picture maybe
like even I'm like this picture of me
for my album wreck right my record
Barbara this picture me - swimsuit with
like these big silicone boobs on I was
like can you I was like can you giant
and she's just like I'm her response is
always like I'm happy you feel that way
about yourself like I don't see and then
usually when she texts me it's some
weird thing out of nowhere some like
Julia Roberts fact like
she loves Julia Roberts yeah she's very
into like Hollywood celebrity female
women especially like from the 90s okay
that's like her whole thing that's her
heir she loves like a Rebecca De Mornay
okay she loves like a Sharon Stone that
you who are yours my like personal
favorites or like who do you do you like
social media let's start there yeah yeah
okay so who are your go-to like follows
on social media like who are you
checking in with oh well like on Twitter
I love I love Chelsea Peretti's account
yeah uh-huh
I love geppu key you know him no oh my
god jubu key is his he's this comedian
and he's a young gay man is his oh my
god so funny he's great he's so funny
the other day he was like you all just
dog on Elizabeth Warren cuz she's a
powerful woman of color and I was like
oh my gosh
okay I'd like this monologue about how
because she's like fake Native American
people hate her
I love Tom Edo on Instagram Tommy
underscore underscore doe yeah oh my god
he takes these pictures and videos of
like rich white hot gays from Instagram
huh and he basically takes it repost it
and gives it new captions like Ernest
parody captions like making fun of
basically like gay Instagram culture
amazing my other new one is on fat gay
fat friend I don't know it master send
you know him I thought master says the
comedian from LA and he takes hot gay
white guy pictures and he reposts him
and he edits himself in and he's like a
six five plus-size guy so he basically
is putting himself in the pictures
having like imagine if these people
actually had a fat friend and it's
himself like next to them like them in a
pool he like puts himself in a swimsuit
with them and these people get really
offended because these like these
Instagram model people have absolutely
no sense of humor oh yeah content your
job that's there are and you are message
there art like my friend Tommy who does
that account he was doing this thing
called like gay throuple there was this
this famous gay couple who their whole
thing is instagramming themselves okay
he was creating content to splice in as
if he was their throuple and he was
always like the left out less hot couple
yeah and they they like contacted him
and threatened him with like bullying
and these these these hottest young gays
have absolutely no sense of humor oh
that's fortunate but isn't it better
that way yeah I guess so that's what you
assume and so to know that that's the
reality is actually yeah people are
wanted it's gay people are routed hot
gay people are extra rod but 20-20-20
those straight people are the they need
to pull it yeah say people are so people
are gay now it's true I think I think
you're absolutely correct straight women
now straight women now are like wearing
rainbow doing anal saying yes Queen
like gay guys now are like sitting home
in like a fishtail braid being like why
are you guys doing your face about it
like the roles now are totally reversed
yeah and it's 2020 it's gonna be a
confusing year I think everyone's gonna
be doing their best yeah whatever that
looks like yeah would you what do you
what do you watch like what do you watch
TV do you watch movies do this in the
music do you sit in the dark with no
noise around you at all
you're gonna laughs like I love video
games oh yeah don't you like Pokemon and
all that stuff I love all that stuff
okay but my like leisure activity yeah
my youtube leisure activity I'm very its
YouTube I don't watch a lot of like
Netflix or anything gotcha I don't
unless you're getting paid yeah watch
that stuff for sure I like the connors I
don't know if it's cool to not like it
without Rosanna okay I think it's so
funny still okay I'll rewatch the office
anytime yeah and then I love YouTube
okay I love like if there's been like a
fight at a mall I've seen it if there's
like a fighter to school I've seen it
you like anything clickbait be like like
security footage of people falling oh
that's what I always say one of my
favorite things is looking up men
falling off boats cuz it's like the guys
that love like their boats and it's like
I'm trying to get on from the dock and
they like fall into the water it's very
fun kids getting hurt anytime kids
getting scared
yeah it's getting scared and crying yeah
I love anything like that I mean I'd
like to watch I love comedy records
I just don't watch a lot of movies or TV
so you don't you don't watch like
reality TV or anything like that no I
mean I think nowadays I barely catch
drag race wow yeah do you feel obligated
to keep up with all of that no and you
know what I think that less TV because I
do a lot of things on camera right keeps
me less nervous on camera Oh logical
that's interesting I don't know like now
my relationship with filming and YouTube
and TV is always the making it yeah not
the consuming it oh no no maybe the
artsy part of me is like trying to keep
a clean pallet of like don't get
influenced yeah no that's true
I
I catch myself sometimes like having to
pull back on watching television because
they just feel like now I'm just
recycling things that have are in my
subconscious that I've seen yeah oh I
love but I also love pranks great scare
tactics really yes there's a show prank
encounters on Netflix where they prank
people oh if you watch the Tracy Morgan
2014 reiteration of scare tactics okay
he's the host but he clearly shot all
the plugs in one day this is in one suit
and it love tracy morgan's it'll be like
a woman game this [ __ ] scared out of her
and like sprinting out of a house and it
costs the tracy morgan being like okay
Christie you better not run out of my
house but things get freaky Tracy Morgan
could like read the phone book
make it funny you know but like I love I
love pranks I like anything where people
in real life are reacting to unrealistic
circumstances thrown off of their normal
yes everyday routine so and reality TV
to me is hard to sometimes get into
because you've been a part of it yes
yeah and you know Dana Gould
I love Dana Gould and he has a section
about reality TV where he says it's
people who aren't actors
performing something that's not written
it's an amateur production of nothing
[Laughter]
they're not actors it's not a play it's
not a TV show it's just people acting in
a way they think they're supposed to act
if it was really happening yeah trying
to act like people yeah and like even on
drag race sometimes I was maybe not the
best reality TV show competitor because
I really shined in the confessionals
when I'm alone recapping the day but
it's only because I find reality TV so
silly that I always felt like a
correspondent live from the scene like
okay all these people who are acting
like TV today this is what they were
doing yeah yeah and like even on TV when
someone like drag queens would sometimes
try like pick a fight and also like
cheat out in the fight they suddenly
move to the other side I would always
see that and be like oh you can [ __ ] it
immediately you're doing this
I guess we're doing this question about
the confessionals did you shoot those
all in one day are those shot like over
the course of the season they would
shoot it at the first thing in the
morning the next day Oh get you it the
best time of the day yeah and I'm a
morning person okay I would wake up you
have my black tee at 7:00 a.m. being
like this [ __ ] start the day yeah you
start the day on camera before you walk
into the workroom so to me it was like
you're already on there's my zip zap zop
yeah well you're a theater kid right yes
unfortunately musical theater but I
don't identify as a musical theater
person that's gonna add cool okay so
you're not into do you go to musical
theater now do you see musicals now no
I've seen cats I mean I was a music
major okay and I transferred to musical
theater because I wanted to learn more
about comedy and movement okay and I
didn't really ever plan on doing musical
theater but I wanted those skills built
up he wanted that to fill your toolbox
yes and for drag it was a great training
because you get to know your body you
get to know your voice the way you look
in the mirror without seeing a mirror
yeah yeah yeah so that was all very
helpful but a musical theater is crazy
and wild Annette's wildin out with Nick
Cannon as cocky would say so I don't
really miss doing it but in my shows
what do i do I do jokes sing songs and
move around I'm not not doing musical
theater give you some good tools to get
to where you are now yeah if reality TV
is an amateur production nothing I guess
what I do is a professional production
of something yeah it's amorphous how do
you prep before shows do you have like a
ritual do you do zip zap zop in the
mirror with yourself do you well do you
do your own makeup in here
I do well when I'm allowed to do you
consider that a ritual for getting ready
I consider it like like putting on
clothes before going on stage like
something that I should do it's not like
Zen for you or or confidence-building or
like no no not in the same way it
probably is for you okay yeah I think
for some people not everyone mm-hmm
like you know in theater like
for me once I might play the old person
okay and I could not get it one
humblebrag
but once I put on like old penny loafers
ah I I thought old age makeup I knew
what an old person was you are in the
zone yes so to me the the getup really
puts me in the place if we had a science
experiment and we did this interview out
of drag and we would have been two
different things completely different
yes different energy I would have been
more talking about it like a you know
like a they'll work someone else does in
a way yeah yeah but for me putting on
makeup takes probably an hour and a half
and then putting on corset and pads and
boobs
am i gluing down my wigs putting on
jewelry my nails that's another 40
minutes so that sort of is a mental that
is meditative though I bet yeah I get in
the tube slide and they come out another
person so yeah so it is very meditative
and then usually especially when I'm
doing stand-up because I play guitar and
my shows I don't want to get nervous so
if I I love to I stand backstage and
play my guitar yeah and just play to
myself because it keeps me from thinking
about anything kyusu being nervous hmm
or I mean that theatre person to me I'll
be backstage doing squats push-ups
planks anything getting the blood
pumping you know hon like at least in
theatre it was always like your body was
the way to get you out of your head yeah
yeah and that always seemed really wish
you washy and I had one of those weird
acting teachers where everything was
abstract yeah but it's amazing huh
especially for singing getting and
getting your body involved get you out
of what you think your body's supposed
to do mmm interesting for comedy at
least yeah where I go out there I need
to be like yeah dancing or moving or
talking or yelling yeah just something
to get your flow going yeah I know
people who like sit there and then walk
out and that's never really been my
stuff no I have to also like jump around
and move around and just like feel maybe
do a couple shots and feel like anything
yes we call that putting on our
personality yeah yeah that's my that's
my zips up top I usually have a Red Bull
yeah and maybe that's signal logical at
this point I have one in my bag I didn't
pull it out because sometimes I feel
like people looking at other people
drinking Red Bull makes them nervous for
some reason
yes or there's a shame attached to it at
least in LA
we'll be like a meth pipe I'm from
Jersey originally and so like that I've
been drinking Red Bull since I was like
10 so to me it's just a go-to it's like
any beverage but I've learned from other
people that it's like that is like a
weapon that you're putting in your body
yeah I'm cocky now one time we had a
long shoot day and we had two red eye
that night so like Australia or
something and we had like three Red
Bulls that day and we got on the plane
we're seeing next to each other and we
were both like never again feel good no
and when you get the shakes at the end
of it your body is like I'm not cold I'm
sweating but I'm shaking at the same
time yeah and you really should sandwich
your Red Bull with like a meal and water
anything honestly start with half the
Red Bull yeah and there's a race I think
there's a responsible way yeah I quit
drinking it I don't smoke so I guess
that's my moment yeah I mean you gotta
replace the behavior what's up haven't
killed anybody
I'm proud of you I guess my only advice
you have a vice what do you do well I'm
also doing dry January right now so I
feel like caffeine is my vice right now
as like a supplemental thing I can't
just say I feel like it's not quiche I
love drinking yeah me too I only stopped
drinking 16 days ago Congrats for
January Jen are you doing just January
well I go on tour February 5th and I
don't really drink before shows good one
the night before I have a show good for
you so if I'm doing back-to-back shows
there is no drinking good for you that's
very professional
I do not abide by those rules I also
have to play guitar right yeah my shows
like 90 minutes and it's just you right
well this year there's also a band and
there's about 11 costumes so too much
going on yeah that makes sense you're
professional and this starts in February
right yeah 29 cities yeah my last tour
was 60 American cities so I'm really
excited to do like half that yes I'm
literally taking confidentiality
breeched
I'm literally probably making $8 on this
tour because I spent so much on costumes
and wigs and band and set pieces and
video and Wow
I really this year I'm doing like the
show of my dreams oh that's so great I
am just so excited and I was just like
well I know that I make a lot of money
traveling with one mic stand in a guitar
but this year let's really like blow
this [ __ ] share of the water let's do
something no drag queen is done let's
make people who've seen me five years in
a row leave and be like [ __ ] my wig
flew that's because you're gonna really
transport people to an experience that I
don't know that they're gonna be
prepared for yeah it's called grown up
and it's about probably like you know
probably like hour and a half um but
it's called growing up it's crazy video
costumes wig reveals there's a full band
playing my record Barbara and I turned
30 this year in the show sort of about
hitting that age where you start to
question whether or not you really have
do you exhibit the the details of an
adult or not yeah and how do you gauge
that and especially when you're a gay
person if you're not married with kids
that's not your benchmark so what are
your benchmarks to feel like an adult oh
that's interesting and I feel like
that's something that you know the age
range of your audience like can relate
to in a lot of different ages you know
yeah I mean I don't know how it is for
heterosexuals but I'm assuming the
pressure is higher when people around
you are getting married with children
you should be like should I write
especially if your inclination is I
don't want to yeah but like should I
yeah and for gay people we don't really
feel that need especially my generation
I didn't grow up thinking I could have a
baby or get married so I didn't think
about it yeah so now it's like well god
I'm a 30 year old man the color of my
living room is baby pink the color is
called Baby Girl doll collection there's
thousands of Barbies and an adult but
it's exactly what it is yeah and I think
the average American little girl owns 11
Barbies mm-hmm so by my calculations I
am what 600 little girls and which means
not if but when I get my period
yikes it's gonna be a doozy you're
always synched up with everyone else and
if you'd like to know more about your
period we have our cool
are you do you still actively collect
alls yes I have one of the most
impressive and beautiful and curated
Barbie doll collections you produce you
do you keep it in your home is it like
on display okay so in my living room
there's probably 50 okay
there's a closet my living room that
probably has my bedroom there's probably
[Laughter]
my boyfriend and I listen three years in
we've dabbled in maybe being open right
and I moved into this condo I live alone
which has only calcified my worse
attributes right yeah and now it's like
wow there was a gentleman caller at my
home and I was like oh [ __ ] I'm that
story now yeah well that's the great
thing is you're giving other people's
stories it's very generous I'm going to
go to a stand-up show and I'm gonna here
I went to this fax house in here for the
collection honestly I think most people
want to sleep with me and gay world
people know who I am so yeah so get that
what do you think boxcars
yeah if you had a mid-century modern
designed home I think you'll be
disappointed well it's all sixties
mid-century okay and it's all gold white
lacquer and baby pink everything yeah I
think that's what people hope for yes
and all the art on the walls either
paintings at me or paintings of Barbie
so you have you live inside of your own
vision board and every wall is just like
guitars you know like a bar cart like
you know big alpaca fuzzy pillows it's
exactly what you'd imagine have you done
a cribs episode yet just throwing it out
there if you guys really run out of
ideas I think people would love to see
your home versus Katya's home well I
think for cribs you only want to do it
if you have like a mansion right and if
you have a fridge full of sodas
I have a three-bedroom penthouse unit in
Hollywood which is rich yeah but won't
look rich because 1,500 square feet
isn't rich - to Kansas are you sure okay
I think I have to buy a million dollar
home in like Wisconsin and then toward
that people be like whoa there's 2021
for you and then people won't judge my
dog collection called it'd be like yeah
I do dabble not many baby dolls I have a
few baby dolls but I think that's where
it gets weird yeah yeah I can see you
having a mixed emotions about the Bumble
baby that's sitting here I can tell you
wanna like it but it is a little
repulsive I don't like baby dolls and I
go to a lot of doll collector shows okay
and that person yeah two seconds for
becoming like a turtleneck gay who has
like tasteful nudes that's I'm like two
seconds from it I mean I'm already like
tall and bald too but these glasses
aren't tight like a- of RuPaul yeah I
mean yeah I got just gotta get that
laughs down like like what is the RuPaul
up it's like it's like it's with the
Cryptkeeper yeah it's like the
Cryptkeeper like suck some helium okay
we're gonna take one last break and now
we have a bunch of Twitter questions for
you so we'll be right back with more not
too deep healthy plant-based non-toxic
cleaning products work and the good ones
are actually more enjoyable to use but
where do you start and who do you trust
that's where Grove collaborative comes
in Grove collaborative is the online
marketplace that delivers all natural
home beauty and personal care products
directly to you grove takes the
guesswork out of going green because
every Grove dot co product is guaranteed
to be good for you
your family your home and the planet
join over half a million families who
trust Grove collaborative to make their
homes happier and healthier plus
shipping is fast and free on your first
order and for a limited time when
listeners go to grove dot ce o-- / grace
you will get a free five piece cleaning
set from mrs. mayors and grove a $30
value go to grove that cos
grace to get this exclusive cleaning
offer Grove dot CEO / grace okay Trixie
before we get into these Twitter
questions I'm going to ask you the two
questions I asked every single guest
that is on the podcast and the first is
who alive or dead would you most want to
throw cold spaghetti act alive or dead
when most when throw cold spaghetti yet
mm-hmm that's an unpleasant feeling I
suppose or it could be celebratory it's
entirely up to your intention I was
gonna say crispy some people really like
like I'm from the Midwest people he
called pasta salad right like thank you
is who really irks me let's see I mean
and this I assume can change on a daily
basis who would I really throw spaghetti
at oh I often have we're drivers slow
down and see me and drag and I watched
them cancel the ride and drive away if I
could like have a handful of spaghetti
I'd whip it at the tercel like I love
that okay the other question is every
single guest is to tell us your worst
pants shooting story or close call but
you can only use three words or three
small phrases so mine for example is
college jogging front lawn okay okay
Provincetown
Massachusetts already nude standing in
front of screen door didn't know what
was gonna happen
wow that really I mean in a very vague
way paints a specific picture yes I was
living alone I didn't know that it was
gonna happen
I was standing nude because I lived
alone and some surprise Wow even that's
you know that's kind of a theme for a
lot of people's pants shooting stories
is the unknown I guess who are the
people who knew who are the people yeah
well a lot of people assumed it was like
a fart situation and it ended up being
something a little bit more catastrophic
yeah yeah Wow but good for you I mean
you were outdoors I assumed it was
indoor carpet it was it was outdoor
carpet indoors
it was like minigolf yeah it was my
first time I performed in a Provincetown
um you know parents in Massachusetts for
the biggest gala yeah and my first year
doing stand-up I went there and
committed to a whole summer of doing an
hour almost every night Wow so I could
really like build the muscles and learn
how to bomb and learn how to yeah learn
how to find out what's funny and I was I
got the smallest cheapest place I could
find it had no air conditioning no Wi-Fi
no fridge oh and I was head indoor
carpet outdoor carpet indoors thank God
easy to hose off yes okay we have a ton
of Twitter questions for you so let's
get into these someone to know what is
one thing you hate about your job and
what is one thing that never gets old
about your job well I mean it's kind of
tacky the the writing a joke and having
it work for the first time mmm is the
best feeling I've been going around LA
and I've been almost every night this
week calling stand-up shows I don't know
and stand up and say can you put me on
for no pay and you can't put because my
contract you can't put me on the roster
anything oh okay I show up and drag for
people who do not know me and I need to
try these sections for my tour that's
having some of them work is so like yes
yeah and that's
always like affirmation that like you do
know your voice not just you know what's
funny but you do know your voice without
being up there and drag yeah your you
know what it will sound like when it
comes out that instrument yeah yeah how
do my jokes don't read us jokes but
dressed up as this Barbie thing with
this dry delivery I was like that will
work yeah you can see the whole picture
yeah around the Jo and the part I don't
like hugging very much I'm sorry I
hugged you when you brought in today I'm
never gonna stop somebody but like you
know I don't I just don't like hugging
and I feel like um if you if you say you
don't like hugs you're a bad person but
you have to hug people I know you know
you're healthy boundaries that's
respectful also hugging a drag queen
it's like hugging a pinata arms out like
you don't want to crunch it oh I'll go
and record saying this too I hate doing
double air kisses I'm consuming I'm
creating my neck and it's always like
some gay guy who like is getting up is a
little too like hey girl Habib and it's
like we've never met already already a
little too like too familiar familiar
yeah and then the air kiss isn't like
who are you performing for because it's
more than that yeah they want to
publicly be seen air kissing or
cross-dressing
you get nothing out of it nothing out of
it okay someone to know if you weren't
on Drag Race
what other reality types show would you
want to be on I see her as a Bad Girls
Club girl myself
oh the Amazing Race
would you really I've always wanted to
uh to do it who would you do it with
Katya oh I think we would just be so
entertaining I think we have very
complementary skills although I think
the storyline is you can only bring one
backpack is that true yeah I mean what I
would have to in drag is putting on
eyelashes and running to like the pit
stop yeah could you imagine not me and
this look like in Taiwan being like I
don't know what you're saying which one
of us wants to rock climb and I also
love I mean um there's this
Oh at the competition show any reality
show um I think that's it yeah I think
you guys would be great on that show I
think it'll be fantastic would you ever
do like a big brother
no yeah Oh Courtney act one big brother
in the UK oh that's right yeah and
Michelle did Big Brother UK and she's
Michelle visage and she was like and so
did Ross right yeah yeah they were all
just like it's crazy it seems like such
a mindfuck
I can't believe someone would do it nah
it's not for me I wouldn't do it it's I
would get too claustrophobic and again
amateur production of nothing yes
I just love though I've seen a couple
episodes of The Celebrity Big Brother
and they're always just wearing the
under I like pads like the cooling pads
it's just constantly like these models
that have agreed to be on the show and
every shot is just them with those gold
under eye pads on I love it
Michelle I believe on her season she's
constantly seen doing her makeup because
you can't listen to music and watch TV I
guess right yeah there's nothing and so
she's just so bored she would just be
putting on and taking off makeup over
and over again
killer just putting on makeup wiping it
off immediately yeah someone's to know
why does Trixie feel the need to dab at
every moment is it for comedic purposes
or just FOMO and missing out on the
trend it's a great question
I love to pick up a trend right when
everyone's dropped it I think that's
funny I love it like I just started
saying like sis that's on period which I
think probably teens on Twitter been
saying for like a year
yeah period with the T at the end and
dabbing I picked up right when like why
would I see someone's like father do it
I mean that was my time yes cuz I think
it's funny to sort of like earnestly try
to do something that is but also I think
it adds just commentary on how stupid it
is it is it also like a drag queen doing
it dumb yeah very silly someone to know
what is your favorite city to do shows
in god I really love show you've been
everywhere everywhere um I really look
out people really love me in the south
hmm and obviously San Francisco LA
Chicago does the Midwest hold a fan base
for you big time I'm from Milwaukee
right yeah so in Milwaukee I'm
definitely like uh walking to college
town I moved 4 and 1/2 years ago so now
I went from being like a hometown hero
to like a fabled unicorn like you know
that used to live here yeah you know
that she still comes here and like
you're a myth yeah now I'll go to my old
favorite bars and then I'll go alone and
have a drink to talk to the bartender's
that I used to work with yeah people
will be staring at me like and I'm sort
of like this is my bar why are you
looking at me I pay for those chips on
the wall I was here when there was a
vending machine in the real jukebox is
there is there Midwest drag yeah sure
really yeah I mean I used to live in
Milwaukee for eight years and I would go
out with just shows into Milwaukee and
then I would take the Amtrak down to
Chicago it's an hour away and do the
shows in Chicago oh cool that was a huge
huge drag trees forget that Chicago is
technically like yeah Midwest Chicago
has probably a big drag show five nights
a week
oh that's cool I'm supposed to know if
you had your own Charlie's Angels who
would be part of the squad oh great
question Nancy Sinatra okay she posted
me on Instagram the other day she posted
a picture of me and I was like oh my god
Wow I mean cuz you know my my divas are
like you know retro divas it's so like
when they notice me or even even if
there's even if there's social media gay
notices me
just feels real to me yeah Nancy Sinatra
Wanda Sykes Wow icon yeah I mean her
records were like some of the first
records I stole on like LimeWire sorry
Wanda and my third one let's say let's
throw in two Kacey Musgraves
oh that's a good trio yeah so we'd have
like a Western Flair yeah I think and
then I think Wanda could be sort of like
the foxy Cleopatra energy yeah yes but
funnier yeah you'd have a lot of
punchline buddy you're an lesbian yeah
win-win and then who was our first one
Nancy Sinatra I think
you would just be sort of like nude with
a guitar just sort of like sort of
posing not doing much yeah but I think
still gets the job done yeah those are
my Charlie's Angels I love that someone
to know if you could get into a
publicity stunt rivalry with any
celebrity who would you choose Oh make
up somebody for the make up community
somebody I want to get cancelled by
Totti expose by Geoffrey I want to get
you know hate tweeted by you know James
Charles I want it all I've never happens
this year's your year I feel a lot of
energy around it we're manifesting this
for you
yes and then um there's a lot of notable
gay celebrities who get in like I don't
want RuPaul to cancel me but I do like
that is a there's a lot of drag queens
and RuPaul's we're palling a lot of drag
queens Deb very star-crossed yeah don't
get along gotcha gotcha gotcha very
public which drag queens hate RuPaul oh
wow which ones he maybe like doesn't
care for yeah yeah oh that's so fun cuz
you know he's like our I mean you sort
of like the pinnacle of greatness in
most ways business-wise drag wise legacy
wise you know yeah and also like with
such accolades you want someone like
that to like almost bless your talent in
a way completely especially since when
you think back of what somebody like
nobody ever talks about people talk
about RuPaul like now yeah because
basically what happened is this is not a
read RuPaul was a one-hit wonder
mm-hmm who fall off the zeitgeist for
about a decade and a half yeah and then
showed up and said hey I'm the most
famous drag queen in the world and these
teens said okay we we believe it and I
mean I like that I like somebody who
just like Alyssa Edwards says before you
sell it you gotta buy it yourself and I
think Paul is really a good self self
sales woman yeah yeah we all could be so
lucky
like I'm Mary Kay okay someone's to know
what made you decide it was finally the
right time to compose and record a song
about Jesse Eisenberg social media I
think he's such a good actor and he's so
hot that you're like type
as my type is you're gonna get my type
really quick my type is like him Michael
Cera oh rogon
I like like a derpy Jewish that's the
energy okay like a derpy Jewish nerd
okay I don't know why hmm I don't know
why if you walk around here for like 15
minutes you'll have a lot of food and I
literally I was writing a song for my
boyfriend because he loves this porn
actor called Jack hunter and I was
writing a song about him and I kind of
ran on inspiration because I don't know
enough about him and I had this idea for
writing a love song about this like a
star mm-hmm and then I went and saw a
zombie land too and it kind of rekindled
how much I love Jesse Eisenberg and I
came home and sat down and wrote Jesse
Jesse and I just loved it
you had you just got true inspiration I
love him I think he's married to like a
French model or something um you know
and it's also you know the fact that
he's not attainable on social media
there's something attractive about like
not being him not gay yeah not hot so
like no one's gonna go to the mat with
me for him
yeah you're in a line of one I think
someone - no guilty pleasure music that
you listen to oh I don't believe in the
guilty pleasure music just pleasure
music I've taken the UK sort of POV you
know in the UK you can go to a night
club and they'll be playing the Spice
Girls at 9 p.m.
yeah no problem just very uh neurotic
Lee they don't care yeah I would say
like my my goof Mike my my my music
where people are like why yeah I love
Michelle Branch Wow I live and breathe
music Michelle Branch Grammy Award
winner songstress I mean I was learning
guitar right wouldn't like everywhere
and like her first few years yeah yeah
yeah so I remembers being 13 and
learning her music that's how I learned
guitar well I like worship now I have a
phone number Wow every so often I get a
little drunk and like yes I just I just
worship her
oh that's amazing I feel like there's a
collab somewhere there so okay if
someone says even if they are small
gestures or words of encouragement what
are some things you do or have done to
help a new or aspiring queen well I'm
not very encouraging okay because I
don't often invite you know wolves into
my henhouse because there's no five drag
jobs and about 4 million drag queens at
this point I imagine it's wildly
competitive yes there used to be this
like Yahoo list that was like things
every day she'd do before they died and
one of the things in the list was do
drag and I was like I'm gonna stop you
right there
that's like saying everybody has to do
comedy you know you don't and I say
there is no point in doing drag unless
you have a crystal clear POV that is
different from other people's oh yeah
that is yeah that you know exactly like
what you offer yeah I mean because then
you're a cover band otherwise like
mm-hmm
what is it how are you different and
what's your skill set it and and what
are you bringing to the drag show that
no one does the Chicago market where I'm
from yeah
they very much valued personas so like
we had you know at the time like pearl
always wore white mhm mhm or like kimchi
always did head pieces at the time she
always had like sky-high sculptures in
her head right my thing was sort of like
the doll thing so it was it was very
valuable to be sort of memorable for one
thing mm-hmm and I think that really
helps me now yeah it's also very helpful
for like building your brand like
knowing exactly what the core of it is
and we will kind of expect and see you
as yeah and put your ear to the ground
and listen to the train tracks and be
like why do people like me don't kid
yourself yeah you're not a singer don't
sing hmm if you're not this just
RuPaul's not the best at everything she
just has smart enough to show herself in
the best light yeah that's that that's
what a real star does that make sense
you think beyonce knows how to French
braid probably not probably not she's
not French braid who sticks to dancing
and singing yeah okay
the stuff she excels at someone to know
what were your major influences for
Barbara well it's a great question um I
sort of fell off the folk music train
and now
I just live and breathe and die for like
sugary 60s music really yes so I love
anything like Motown and girl groups oh
I love surf rock and I also love like
Fountains of Wayne Weezer
the go-go's the Donna's I love like
girly sugary rock music cool Veruca Salt
and so this album is a lot of that it's
a lot of like pop melodies but it's
we're playing plugged in guitars and
hand clapping and smiling and my
original sketch for Trixie was sort of
this beach bunny Malibu Barbie with this
like dark sense of humor yeah and I kind
of like looked at my original idea for
Trixie and kind of redid it because this
album is very beachy and very very
Malibu Barbie well you're going back to
your roots it sounds like a little bit
yes okay one of the last questions is
there a particular part of your upcoming
growing up tour that you are extra asite
excited to share with audiences yeah the
touring with a band for the first time a
real band for the first time three young
heterosexual men who have no shame in
playing for a drag queen it's just
pretty amazing how did you get the band
like how did you did you audition people
did you just natural collaborators I
found somebody I liked and I said this
is the instruments I need pick people
you like that you know that you want a
tour with okay because that really is
yeah you guys like Tori on a tour bus oh
so you don't get to know each other real
well yes so I'm in this back bedroom
suite you know like a real omed bedroom
so yeah and then the band and the
production people are in these like bunk
beds yeah a little cubby beds yes and I
just think it's important to hire
straight people because representation
matters and they've been in the dark
long but if you think we're a real
production literally I had to buy the
matching suits for the tour we went to
the Grove we went to the Grove and I
took the Mazzara try on suits see this
should be filmed this seems like an
opening video yeah then I took them to
Nordstrom's and bought them all like
matching smoking loafers whether they're
in beautiful series Wow and they all
match and they look incredible and
honestly it was just maybe it's my like
internalized homophobia I was just so
pleased that I found people to play for
me
embarrassed of it oh that's great no
well I mean when do you start you start
in February yeah we're going to
rehearsals next week and we start for a
briefing that's so exciting
Trixie this was so fun we've reached the
end of the podcast but before you go
everyone that agrees to be a guest gets
a personalized fortune cookie from us to
them so this is for you by the way this
is my breakfast
there you go we aim to provide I think
it's vegetarian
very ASMR Oh anything could happen in
2020 you plus Paul Rudd you never know
I dunno get this my friend worked with
him I might put on a production uh-huh
and she sent me a video of him saying hi
Trixie thank you so much for loving me
like I guess he listened the secret is
you talk about someone enough they find
out you like them yeah I also love
Michael Cera and last year on tour I had
a song called his Michael Cera hot where
I showed a slideshow of him for movies
and we debated his hotness cuz he's one
of those people pictured a picture he's
either disgusting or gorgeous one of my
friends does make up for him and sent
him the video
and he was you know he responded but I
think that's really cool at least he
knows oh that's amazing
I can see Paul Rudd showing up at one of
your shows well at least Paul Rudd is
universally hi yeah Paul Rudd I think
everyone can agree is hot my boyfriend
looks at me we were watching cursed and
we were watching Jesse Eisenberg and my
boy was like am i disgusting because you
like someone who's disgusting yeah I'm
seeing your taste levels and I'm
reflecting back on our relationship I
have some questions let's just say I get
very attracted to the pineapple pizza of
men fight people you've got a bum leg
but like nice brows
over here amazing Trixie where can
people find you and everything that
you're up to if they don't already know
can find me on every social media
platform at Trixie Mattel and you can
follow some of my products at Trixie
cosmetics we post new products and stuff
every day and I throw a lot of stuff
that only gets posted on the cosmetics
account Oh sweetie really like my
message yesterday that was like
everything's on sale for the same price
as always I love it throwing people in a
really Pleasant way yeah
and tickets for tours still available
yeah Trixie Mattel calm I'm in 30 cities
in America and then about 15 European
ones this spring so awesome and come
they can pre-order the book oh we got
pre-order the book on Amazon now so much
crazy that book is so [ __ ] funny oh I
can't wait my parts are funny read it
for cockiest parts because that [ __ ] is
crazy oh that's so awesome I'm so
excited just on everything thank you so
much [ __ ] going on guys go check out
Trixie if you haven't I'm sure you
already know everything that she's up to
but please go check it out and we'll see
you guys next time on another episode of
not too deep goodbye 2deep 2deep 2deep
2deep not too deep is a production of
grace helbig incorporated producer
Melissa D months edited by Shireen Loni
Eunice
post production sound by Chris Henry and
an extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]